this is the first time this is happening
in Europe wo
with brothers and sisters I'm not making
woodo with milk but it's true that this
is the first time that this happened in
Europe it's never ever done before
nothing like it whatsoever what is it
listen closely we were shocked to find
out how many Muslims don't know how to
pray Salah and we have found a solution
we want to start Salah hubs across
Europe a place where they can come and
learn the Salah and leave learning the
whole Salah on their own we've already
done it in London but we don't have
enough funds to start in Europe if only
a thousand of you guys come and give
£100 each we can make this a reality
with dedicated and qualified instructors
teaching people how to pra Salah how
crazy is it that till this day we have
no service like it be the one who made
this project happen with the money Allah
gave you click the link or the button
and donate now just imagine Allah seeing
you donating the money he gave you for
people to worship Him be one of the
thousand people we need to give £100 or
more